what president biden has done with his
border opening up now we're catching
people on the terrorist watch list
fentanyl has increased by 300 percent
killing americans as we come across
more than a million people have come
across this border illegally now
kevin mccarthy house minority leader
criticizing president biden as the
country gets ready to end pandemic
travel restrictions
a move that has some saying the migrant
surge of the southern border will only
get from
worse from here texas governor greg
abbott with me now and governor good
morning to you and welcome back to our
program got a lot to cover
thank you bill if you change title 42
how does that affect how you control the
border
this is going to be a total disaster
it's going to be a health care disaster
as well as a
humanitarian disaster but also bill it
underscores one
very important point that your audience
as well as all americans need to
understand and that is
president biden doesn't really care
about the people in texas or
citizens of the united states of america
president biden is
catering to people who are coming from
the 150
countries across the globe he cares more
about people who are outside
america than those who are inside
america and that's exactly why
i and other governors are working to
help do
the president's job america's job we are
trying to step up and secure the border
including trying to
reduce this influx i'm going to be back
down on the border again
tomorrow working to make sure that we
are accelerating the process of building
the wall
accelerating the process of arresting
these people who are coming across the
border because
somebody has to step up and secure the
border because the body administration
has completely abandoned its
responsibility to his
fellow americans can you confirm this i
i saw a number here if the current pace
continues
by the end of this year the total number
of border interdictions will be the
highest we have seen
in 70 years and that's exactly what we
are saying record after record after
record is being broken
and the amazing thing about it which was
part of the lead-in is the byte
administration still says
oh the border is closed it eliminates
any sense of credibility that either
president biden or his administration
has about
anything let's go back in time real
quick to a couple of couple of things
together you remember
when i opened up texas 100 and called me
a neanderthal and was completely wrong
about that
he's completely wrong and lying to
america and what they are saying about
the border there is zero credibility in
the white house because
they are destroying america one of the
fundamental responsibilities of the
president
of our country is to protect our
sovereignty uh and
biden has now abandoned his
responsibility
to pro to protect the sovereignty of the
united states of america well um you
said the other day you're trying to
you're trying to raise millions to
continue building the wall
i saw a number early in the week you
were a long way off i saw 700 000
raised so far um it seems like there's a
way to go
yeah but understand this bill and your
audience needs to know this and that is
that the money that's coming in is being
donated
it helps obviously because we'll take
all the money we can get but it's a
fraction
of what the state will be putting in the
state of texas
is going to put in a lot of money to
build the wall and you also need to know
that the progress being made for the
construction of the wall
is actually going along faster than what
i anticipated
we're still in the process of hiring a
program manager however
even while we're trying to hire the
program manager and do requests for
proposals
we already have a lot of proposals
showing
that we will be able to build the wall
faster and cheaper
than what was done under the trump
administration okay last topic here you
know the democrats from austin are still
in washington d.c
don't know if you have an update on
their status as to whether or not
they're coming home but the house
speaker dave phelan says this
i am demanding all of our colleagues in
d.c to contact my staff immediately
in order to secure their seat on the
plane and return to austin in order to
do the state's business
the state of texas is waiting apparently
he wants to charter a flight
to bring him back home do you anticipate
these democrats will come back
any time before the 7th of august which
at the moment
is the time when this special session
would expire governor
right and so that that is impossible to
tell here's what we can figure out
uh and that is we have seen that the
democrats have exec
have no game plan whatsoever about how
to deal with this they
they go up there and they've gotten a
whole lot of attention this week but all
that's going to begin to fade
over the weekend and into next week and
what we are
are already seeing and that is their own
constituents the people who voted them
into office
they're getting up in arm and getting
very angry because there are so many
different pieces of business such as
helping out our teachers such as
reducing property taxes such as
preventing dangerous criminals who were
released on bail from killing other
people
there are so many laws we need to pass
that these lawmakers are preventing from
being passed
these lawmakers are making texas more
dangerous
because of their absence and the people
of texas know that
and so these democrats are risking their
own future their own jobs
by being voted out of office last thing
i'll tell you about this bill and that
is
they can stay away as long as they want
i will continue calling special session
after special session
so they they can run but they cannot
hide
so i take it they will not take speaker
phalen up on his offer
at the moment governor thank you for
your time we'll see where it is next
week
governor abbott thanks in texas thank
you bill hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary
any great news bites any great
interviews coming your way on fox you
can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now